lockdown parties groping allegations and
now cabinet resignations in altringham
in greater manchester an area of
traditionally strong conservative
support has patience with the prime
minister run out for the lockdown
stories and the party gates and that
sort of thing i mean you know i'm not
enough i don't think the prime minister
should resign though because um if he
resigned who would replace him at the
moment how many times do you say oh i
forgot i didn't know i was unaware
his other
doing a terrible job or he's got a
terrible memory either way he's not
suitable for this job is he the jubilee
bunting is still in place but mention
the word politics here tonight and
things are certainly less cheery this is
an area that has always voted
conservative but amongst the party
faithful even there the mood is somewhat
somber
in the local conservative club there is
deep frustration and not just towards
the man in charge i think it's just been
a slow slow death
and i don't think he's done anybody any
any favors himself included
the cabinets around him have got a lot
to answer for
um
and in my opinion
uh
well what's your next question going to
be well who would replace me that's
right
and for me it can't be any of the
cabinet because i think they're all
colored with the events of the last few
months but the last few months have also
involved a cost of living crisis and a
war in europe within their own family
the chogadis don't know if this is the
right time for change boris johnson
should not resign because
surely at this point if the change of
government will give more upheaval to
the to the country uh rishi shanak and
sajid javid have been
through him through all these other
times and this has been the last draw
for them i think for quite a lot of
other mps it might also be as well and
if they go will more voters even in
areas like this one follow
catherine of autopsy sky news in greater
manchester